Ryan's in Biloxi Mississippi hey Ryan
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
it's an honor to talk to you - sir
what's up my question was about your
credit score so I've only had one loan
in my life I'm 22 years old right now I
had a small auto loan when I bought my
first car I paid that off I'm completely
debt-free right now mm-hmm well I I
decided to hop on Credit Karma a little
bit ago about a month ago when I first
checked my credit score just develop
urea to see what it was
and there's actually a credit for this
so my question was how long after you
pay your last debt off because your
score eventually dropped to zero
well our typical experience has been
because we don't know no one knows
except I Fair Isaac who runs FICO okay
they're the only ones that actually know
their algorithm but it appears between
six months and a year from the time that
you have all zero balances and no open
accounts if you have a credit card and
you're paying it off every month that's
an open account right okay that you can
have no debt and still have a credit
score all the time okay so if anybody is
reporting on you and the only way that
would happen is if you have an ongoing
relationship with them meaning you still
owe them money or you're still using
their product even though you're paying
it off every month it could be an MX
card then you will always maintain a
credit score of some kind so the only
way is if you have absent you go off the
grid basically you're saying I have zero
accounts open and zero balances of any
kind no bad debt no good debt no no debt
that I pay off every month no that of
any kind roughly six months to a year
later we're finding people's credit
score disappears disappears now when I
first started this I still had a
bankruptcy showing on mine and so it was
not going to go away for a while because
I had this bankruptcy showing in a
chapter 7 bankruptcy will report on you
for
ten years it'll show up on your credit
bureau reporter and some of the old
creditors that you bankrupt on that you
don't pay they might report after the
bankruptcy they're not supposed to but
sometimes their computers kick out that
they still haven't gotten paid well
they're not going to get paid because
chapter 7 they got 0 and I had two of
them or three of them reports three
years later and that started the whole
process over I had to go back and
dispute those because they were not
allowed to report that they did
ultimately get paid because I went back
and paid in my bankruptcy but as a moral
thing not as a legal thing but anyway
all that to say you've got to have the
thing completely squeaky clean and then
apparently if they haven't changed it
this month and they don't start counting
your rent or they didn't start counting
something else that we don't know that
they count then your credit score will
go to zero which is what we call it but
they technically call it indeterminable
because they have no way to determine a
credit score they actually sent me an
email back in the day that said you know
we want to check on you because our
credit score is your credit score has
disappeared you were now undeterminable
and we wanted to make sure there was not
a mistake or that you weren't dead and I
kind of thought that was a threat but
little subtle passive-aggressive it's
like when a southerner says bless your
heart you know I mean it's the same
thing right
yeah but yeah I've had zero for gosh 25
26 27 years or something like that had
an indeterminable credit score and I've
had an indeterminable amount of money as
a result because I don't have any
payments it's a pretty amazing thing